Hey Ya chin and Jade would not leave
each other's side does not each other
side I appreciate at least shouldn't
show the [ __ ] up cat what's up man she's
busy I was with my sister and my cousin
brought her fine ass to the party I
didn't know that was loud
oh come on I mean I don't like your
hotter sister at the party fair I don't
dress like a rapper for sister loves
like the wait can you elaborate nope
yeah but you know what I'm saying
nope sure caster can't mm-hmm
uh yeah we had a that didn't [ __ ]
come in no show that's right that's
right
I'll come to Vegas you come to Vegas
yeah I'll come to Vega real you want to
come to Vegas yeah all right I'm sure
the fans love to see you yeah could get
weird there whatever we'll figure it out
yeah you come out chin Kane wouldn't
leave J side and then you were chatting
up my car guy Greg on the dock on the
car G yeah I was with a not for me died
hey don't waste this time a couple thing
you took him down to my car and then you
like chat about car awful thing I feel
bad for your lover I told Greg I've told
my dad I feel bad for Gregor's right
Ryan's waste this time thinking about
call I was with Jay when I was talking
to him so you'll like this cuz first I
look at the Ferrari now that Ferrari
they're not gonna be making those
Ferraris anymore because they're too
powerful heat will and usually you need
someone from Ferrari to come to teach
you how to drive that car which I'm sure
you know yeah as racy car a racing car
driver I mean I was sat in there and
it's it's Spartan there's no gadgets
it's only for driving fast right that's
craziness so I'm looking at I'm like
Jesus all right whatever is going a
beaut alone it is a thing of beauty
called the stone yeah now when he told
me how much it actually costs if you
bought a new it's a condo on wheels it's
a condo on wheels and it's a nice condo
on with that's fine Congrats on
everything thanks dude now I see now I
say to him I go Jays there I go now what
car should I Drive it's integrated yeah
and then he goes I mean I'd have you in
a twin turbo Porsche
yeah Hannibal ba ba-ba-ba-ba and I'm
like how much does that ego everything
you know is that then I go well what did
my payment he goes about twenty five
hundred bucks a month and I go yeah then
he goes but you know now there's now
what we'd have though there's also the
twinkle and he starts going through all
the details and I go I don't want these
I came to my senses I can't I said good
realize that you know I just wanna I
want a nice torque I mean looking at our
guy I think now that's a cardan gets you
and I can get you in that car and I got
car will take you out there I'll show it
to you because if you gotta go
I finally I don't want a car I'm out I
got poured of the whole conversation
he's a Chatty Cathy dude he's great
though he knows what did he say when he
walked in my house oh this is the best
he walks in I couldn't believe he said
it out loud he walks in and he goes yep
these people have way more money than we
do you a lion
fin you don't say that loud because I'm
just saying that nobody's the same mom
it was great yep these people have way
more money than we do smart kid like
what the [ __ ] is going on it's hilarious
though I know your house is is nice uh I
think your house isn't I don't think
you'd ever have to move out of there cuz
it's it's like birth date in terms of
not too big not too you know it's like
it's what you need that layout is
perfect a rough video yeah but it's
nicer it's got taste like Young Jeezy's
house you know no but it's got his taste
it's tastefully done so there is a clip
of Arnold Schwarzenegger while he's at
an Arnold event in South Africa a crazed
fan came and tried to dropkick him
basically
Arnold is okay and he says that he's
just happy the guy didn't disrupt a
snapchat here's the thing get a free
drop kick on Arnold granted his
nicknames the oak the kiddin embodies
like that's why hitting his back yeah
but in the video that Arnold post it
looks like I thought yeah her dad me and
Jay over in New York goin I'll [ __ ]
don't [ __ ] up Arnold but then when I
saw this angle yeah like I wasn't [ __ ]
and the guy does this egg the guy's
known for these stunts Oh is he know
bag that body goes really my party guys
not week we get our own item faced
Arnold's wool they all still swollen
yeah what a piece of I'm speaking of
just natural DNA I finally connected
Bobby Lee and did their podcast Ike
tiger belly yesterday
do you hear Santino I'm Bobby Lee going
bad on me no it's hilarious on their
podcast yeah bring it up on Fighter
indicated website he's firing the kid
website I'm firing a kid dad Instagram
oh there are YouTube I think was instant
you pussycat yeah somebody did I believe
it was the fake inning that's my uh
which one is it that one the middle one
this is Bobby Lee and Santino on tiger
belly I think it was on Santino show
zone oh he had he was worse and more
stuff than he was good in okay I'll say
about Brian I don't say that he is bad
and more stuff that he is good in stuff
instead of twice right yeah don't say
that out loud thought Bryan Callen I
said it once I'll say it a thousand
times
if he wants to fight we can set it up
you you know that I could stop your
heart right I always forget though he's
like 70 52 in the 83 all right he does
things world he'll send me videos it'll
just do going around he sends me phrase
dress all the phrase and I wanna go and
kill him because of yeah yeah he thinks
he's funny
good night so it's bleach media not the
favorite [ __ ]
yeah so with uh with so that I was they
do it out of Bobby's house mmm
like they live upstairs I get you care
all Bobby's Bobby's just waking up I'd
be down I'm like it's horrible that's
annoying Tim it's one o'clock yeah yeah
so anyways finally did their show which
I supposed to do a long time and his
girl died me dime he knows this oh yeah
die me dime evolves swimmer
I don't think swimmer yep but
where do you give out our athletic
achievements cuz we talked about that
when we did the podcast yeah did your
athletic well she's in athletic she's a
big athletic cow and she's with Bobby
who's not a big athletic guy that we're
saying she's so attractive to offices
and this is where I'm telling with this
thing is yes so we are talking about
attractiveness and she goes well you
know whether Bob you know Bobby's date
supermodels before and the reason we
connected because of our personalities I
might hold on hold on I mean I will
promise you this
kyla right kalila kalila I would said I
will promise you Scylla if you didn't
look that way you guys would not be here
you might in this just the way it works
like attraction initially is the way you
guys connected then if you guys vibe
then there's usually a for a longer
relationship but if you didn't look like
that you wouldn't even have the
opportunity for you guys divided and
because that's the only way the only
thing that's gonna track this off the
bat yeah is that physical attraction if
you want to go well you gotta look
deeper than the skin no I get that
no it's in my DNA to be attracted to my
tie that's right so as soon as I meet
someone if I'm attracted to him
physically alright check that dicks hard
and then you talk to him and then if
they're got a personality then you move
them in have kids but we're not even
gonna get to that phase if you don't
check be a guy in DC zoo Washington DC
zoo when I was in college
stole two gaboon Vipers one bring up a
goblin the biggest Viper in the world
stole two gaboon Vipers and they he was
on the bus he had him in a burlap sack
now they have the long ever long spanks
of any [ __ ] snake look at how big
there was he gonna do so he can kill an
elephant short enough fat huh oh and
there there holy died better yet some
torch the fangs can go two inches long
Billy got some torque eat or do ya bit
got that short fat dick yes okay Lauren
the world know you have you ever seen
that
oh good remember there's a documentary
on HBO
it falls prostitutes there's a series on
HBO and me and my roommates in college
used to watching there's nothing funny
this guy picks up this [ __ ] you know
prostitute or Pro this hooker
and they were falling around this black
girl and it's like this you know fat
like white dude and she gets in his and
she's miked up and she gets in their
ages there she was ooh
because he liked that she goes it
subtitles so you can understand I said
yes but oh you got that short fat dick
never forget they got that guy boom
Viper a bit like I was like hey man
don't want this that ain't good it's not
good well so this thing bit him this kid
through the bag on the bus oh my god
yeah and he was paralyzed for life
minimum ha he had a strong storms back
Milan Hey right through the burlap sack
beer back and he was like ah I don't
feel so good don't feel so good yep and
he's all he was yeah he got paralyzed
well we don't want to [ __ ] he wasn't
see a lot of times well yeah I'm gonna
steal a couple gaboon viper doesn't even
get him in the bag teenage kid how do
you give them in the back so you can
catch him you use that there there's a
yeah you're Wrangler [ __ ] that gaboon
Vipers are I've never seen a note just
aches
dude I was hiking my dad yesterday and
there's a snake on the trail and I
[ __ ] ran the other direction my dad
goes oh my god you're scared of snakes
I'm all who's not who's nuts all right
when I asserted I went my bat Indiana
Jones yeah a little skier that [ __ ]
rattlesnake up yeah yeah rattle snakes
and vipers when they bite you a
rattlesnakes a Viper you don't want to
get bit by a Viper look at that enjoy
that way stinks
those teeth into your lack [ __ ] and the
end and shoots a bunch of neurotoxin in
your about a cool animal oh yeah when
you see my back rip I pull myself up
like a champ thirty times while talking
to you why wouldn't I give that to you
as it's a gift it's a gift it's a gift